[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
BENJI BENNETT: Thank you
so much for having me here
to Google today.
To have the
opportunity to follow
in the footsteps of people who
have done these Google Talks is
pretty daunting, I have to say.
I do have a bit of
a cough, so you'll
have to excuse me if I
have to take a moment.
So I always-- when
I do a talk, I
set out a little
bit of housekeeping.
What I'm going to
be talking about
is a very emotional
subject to me personally.
And I'm sure you
will probably find it
quite an emotional
subject to listen to.
So if I have to
take a moment, it's
not because I'm
going to lose it.
Sometimes I just have
to take a second just
to get myself back
together, because I
can get quite emotional
having these conversations.
So you're welcome
to laugh at me when
I have those moments as well.
So what I'd like to do
is to try and just--
is to get to know you
guys a small little bit.
And I was thinking
about this last night,
and it will help me to
make some of my points
a little bit clearer.
In life, everybody is
struggling with something.
Whether it's within
your own mind
or whether it's
external to your mind.
It's somebody in your family, a
sickness, a death, an illness,
stress, worry, mental
anxiety, and so on, we all
have something to worry about.
And they are all
equally the same.
There is nothing stronger or
worse than anybody else's pain
or issues that they have.
So my whole talk,
really, is about family.
And there was two things I
was thinking of last night
that I'd like to start off.
I'm going to do a little survey.
Now, you can put up your
hand or not, whichever you're
feeling comfortable with.
But hopefully, you'll just
bear with me for a second.
So everybody here is
working in Google.
So my first question is when
you were in school and college,
was Google going to be your
number one place to work?
When you were in college, you
said, right, I'm in school.
I'm going to leave
school, I'm going
to go to college because
I want to be in Google.
Hands up who had that
thought in their mindset
when they were studying.
Good.
[LAUGHTER]
Great.
We had one.
OK, he's a real Googler.
He watched that movie we all
watched, and we loved it.
OK.
So that's good.
Now, how many of you now have
a qualification or a training
relative to working in Google?
So I presume most of you would
have some sort of qualification
or degree or whatever.
So a lot of you have trained
to do a job that you never
really thought that
you would be doing.
Now, bear with me for a second.
The other side of
this little equation--
hands up here, anybody
who have children.
OK.
So there's is a good
few who have children.
Anybody-- you don't
have to answer this--
anybody here in a relationship
that hope maybe one
day they will have a family?
OK.
Now, finally, anybody who
hasn't put their hand up,
is anybody here who was ever in
school when they were younger--
oh, when I grow up, I'm
going to have a family,
and get married, and have kids.
Does that cover the
rest of you here?
OK.
So the point-- why
I wanted to ask
this was that I think it's
fair to say everybody, pretty
much, in the room has an
aspiration to be a parent.
Anybody in this room
have any formal training
on being a parent?
Yes.
Great.
So this has all worked
exactly how I imagined it
at 2 o'clock this morning
when I was going, OK, what--
so the point to
all of this, if you
can let me be a little bit
relaxed on the actual stats,
everybody here
never really thought
about working for
Google yet you're
trained to do a job in Google.
And everybody here
has an aspiration--
is or would like to be a
parent, and you have no training
to be a parent.
So what effectively is the most
important job of everybody's
life is that of being a parent.
And there is no formal
training out there.
And that's really the basis of
what my whole message is about
and what I'm trying to do.
I'm not a trained psychologist.
I have a master's in
international business.
I've been in the
corporate business before.
So by the experience
that I've been on,
I have been inspired
to not tell people
how to raise their children,
or what to do, or what to eat,
or what to put on
them, or what to say.
All I'm trying to do is
to encourage families
to have more fun together.
And that's the essence
of everything I do.
I always call it the
love, hugs, and kisses.
So if we can, in our
families, as parents,
spend more time engaging
with our children,
show them the love,
bring them out in nature
and engage with them
a little bit more,
I think the world would
be a better place.
One of the other analogies
I was thinking of
was parenting is like
being a government.
You do your best.
Not everybody is happy.
And most politicians on our
end have no formal training
of being in government,
and they all go
and they do what
they have to do.
And then you give
the kids too much.
They'll be given out, or
they will be complaining,
or they want something,
or they'll be bold,
or they'll go on
strike, or whatever
it is as the children
are getting older.
So now we have the boss guys.
They're all old.
They have their own
voice, and they are now
being bold children.
Or they are being good children,
because the parents were
useless in the first place.
So there's the
conflict right there
between parenting and children.
Now, we've all had
different kinds of parents.
And God forbid we'd all have
Donald Trump or Vladimir Putin
as our analogy of
parents, but there
are parents in that
kind of category
who are just in
it for themselves.
They can become quite selfish.
They're not really caring about
their children or their country
so far as to what's
going on in Syria.
So I just wanted to
make that analogy
of the importance of parenting
and the importance of having
some sort of information
about how to parent.
And it always boils
down to spending time.
When you're with them, be
with them, and encourage them,
inspire them, and spend
your time with them.
And as I have now, is reading.
So that's a little
analogy of what
I wanted to say in terms of
what the content of my story is.
So I'm going to tell
a bit about myself.
So like you, 10 years ago,
I was in a corporate world.
I worked in Vodafone.
My job was pricing.
And the idea was how can
we have a pricing plan that
makes people think that they're
getting great value for money
but spend double the
amount of money with this.
So I'm sure you're all
the same at Google.
You're all the same in Google.
How do I get--
and I'm one of those people,
oh, ads, and oh, so on.
[LAUGHTER]
And I wanted to climb
that corporate ladder.
And now we're on this other
side of this whole equation
I'm talking about, which is
our work-life balance is so--
luckily, I went to work,
I worked really hard,
I was on my way
going up the ranks,
and I always had
time for my family.
Weekends were always sacred,
and we would always go out.
It would always be an outing
or a walk to the beach,
the park, whatever it is.
And it was one summer.
And we have a place down in
Brittas Bay It's a mobile home.
I was there last
night, actually.
If any of you are on
Facebook, it's Adam's Cloud.
You see a photograph
that I took--
not last night, but
the night before.
And it's quite magical
and incredible.
That photograph is what
I call Adam's bench.
And I'm going to talk
about Adam now in a moment.
So 10 years ago, we were down
in this spiritual and magical
place called Brittas Bay.
And we have a caravan
beside the sea,
and myself and my wife
Jackie, who we met at work,
we would go down with our
three children, Henry, Adam,
and Robbie.
And we loved it.
We'd go down at winter,
we'd go down at Easter,
we'd go down at weekends.
And I was on my
holidays from work.
And I was sitting on the
deck, looking out to the kids.
They had just cut the grass.
The kids are making
haystacks with it.
The sun was shining down.
Sorry.
This is one of those emotional
moments I was telling you
about, so feel free to laugh.
So the sun was shining down,
and I raised a glass of wine
to my wife, and I
said, we're in heaven.
I have a good job.
Look at our kids.
We're here in this
holiday place.
The sun is shining.
It's just incredible.
I was in this
bubble of happiness.
And I try always to
stay in my bubble.
And literally at that moment,
our then-four-year-old Adam
came up onto the deck
complaining of a headache.
And like all parents, you
think the worst-- oh, my god.
Oh, don't be silly.
Anyway, go on into bed
and have a lie down.
We gave him some calpol.
That night, he was up all night.
He was complaining
of a headache.
And then the next day, he was
complaining of a headache.
And then he started vomiting.
So then we were starting
to get a little concerned.
We brought him to the doctor.
The doctor looked in his
ear, looked at his heart,
looked down his throat.
He said, he seems fine to me.
I think everything is OK here.
Give him some Motilum.
It will settle his stomach.
And give him some calpol
and see how he goes.
That night-- my wife had
done the previous night.
She was up all night.
And I said, look, I'll take
Adam into bed and I mind him
tonight.
You have a rest.
I didn't sleep a wink.
Adam was up all night.
He was getting sick.
He was complaining
of a headache.
And I went, something is
really not right here.
So the next day, we
brought him to hospital.
Though I'd just had
my two weeks holidays.
It was a Monday.
I was due to go
back to work Monday.
And I went, oh, great, day off.
Bring him up.
Get him sorted out, and then
we'll be back down later on.
We went up.
He was admitted into hospital.
And within about 30
minutes, he got sick.
I lifted him in my arms,
and he went like this.
And that was it.
Now, he was kept alive through
the advances of medicine
for another number of hours,
and they operated on him.
And we had no idea
what was wrong.
What's wrong, doctor?
It could be meningitis.
We don't know.
He came in with a headache.
And so it turned out that he
had a massive brain tumor.
I've never researched it,
because I just can't go there.
But it was a vascular
tumor that just bled.
So essentially, he
had a massive bleed
in his brain, which
caused the swelling, which
caused the vomiting, which
caused the headaches.
So we went from the happiest
people-- we have life sorted,
we know what's life.
We spend time with our
kids, we're working,
we're doing what we were
supposed to be doing,
we were just finished our
holidays, to Adam is gone.
And Adam had an older
brother who was 6 and 1/2
and a younger brother,
Robbie, who was just gone 1.
Now, that day I
brought him to hospital
just happened to be my birthday.
So that's a lovely time
of the year for me.
So after all of the
madness and the--
it was very calm, actually.
It was a very, very
calm experience.
There was no shouting
or running around.
It was actually-- if it
doesn't sound too strange,
it was beautiful
the way he left us.
It was very, very special.
And immediately, at that moment,
I turned to Jackie and I said,
we were very-- we told Adam
we loved him every day.
I played football with
him when he wanted.
We spent time.
He got so much in
in those four years.
And I immediately said,
I have to tell people,
I have to remind people that
there's so much to life.
And children need so much
time and love and affection
and encouragement and
all of those things,
and confidence building.
And I said I need
to remind people.
Now, it wasn't a big
stick of, oh, you
need to spend time
with your kids.
It was just that reminder that
I wanted to get out there.
So I immediately started writing
without any thought process
in my mind at all.
So I started writing,
which I've never published,
which is a book about
a time I went camping.
Adam was four years of age, and
we went camping out overnight.
And Robbie was at
home with his mom.
And we had an amazing night--
Harry, myself, and a few
others, and of course, Adam.
And so then this whole thing of,
OK, I've got to remind parents.
What do we do?
So I said, OK--
and I mentioned this at
my speech at the funeral--
if every parent can spend
an extra 10 minutes a day
and tell their children the love
them before they go to sleep,
the world will be
a better place.
Because if any of who have
the children here are like me,
I shout and scream at them,
and I'm giving a hey, come on,
put your coat on.
Hurry up.
For God's sake, eat your dinner.
And we're all doing that.
So if you think of
a small person who
are getting those messages
all day of hurry up,
and come on, and quickly, and
you're late, or whatever--
and then they go to
bed, and all of that
is in their mind for the day.
They wake up the next day,
and then it starts again.
There's no break.
There's no, OK, what am I doing.
Why are people at
me all the time?
Because we're all busy.
And it's what most parents do--
well, the Irish ones, anyway.
So the point is that 10 minutes
at the end of the day telling
your children you love
them is a big, huge eraser.
It rubs out all the shouting.
And it sends them to bed happy,
knowing that they're loved.
And they are going to
have a nicer sleep,
and they're going to wake up the
next morning feeling happier.
Now, as I said, I'm not
a trained psychologist.
But I'm a huge believer that
that 10 minutes every night
spent with children, I believe--
and I have no research
to back this up--
is going to help with so
many mental health issues,
anxiety issues with
children, confidence issues--
Everything that children need,
just that 10 minutes every day
is going to help
and if nothing else
was done other than a walk in
the park and that 10 minutes
one on one at bedtime where
you can have your chat.
So that's my message,
and that's what
I have been inspired about.
And going back to love,
loss, and inspiration--
I couldn't have loved
Adam any more than--
it was impossible to
love any of my children,
and my wife, indeed,
of course, as well.
He was gone.
He was lost.
And now I've been
inspired with a message
to try and change the world
is what I'm trying to do.
I'm doing it on my own.
So I wrote this book,
"Before You Sleep."
And it just represents
a parent and a child
together going on magical
adventures together.
And the text is very simple.
"I love you much more than
the sun, moon, and stars,
even much more than
the red planet, Mars.
If we could together fly in
a big rocket ship, what fun
we would have on
a magical trip."
And so it goes on.
And it references
love to the love of--
I love you much
more than pirates,
and Halloween, and Christmas,
and diggers, and dinosaurs,
and all the stuff
that kids love,
and parents actually
love as well.
But it also then relates
the reader and the child
in the book together going
on their magical adventure.
So it brings that bond together.
So without knowing anything
about the publishing industry,
I publish my book.
What does that mean?
It means you've got to finance
it and find a way to sell it.
Everyone would say, how
did you publish your book?
And I went, well, I don't know.
I just printed it and
am trying to sell it,
and that's publishing.
And ignorance is bliss, because
I had no idea how many books I
would sell, and so on.
So I printed 10,000 copies.
And we used to
laugh in my family.
We'd go, oh, Jesus.
He's printed 10,000 copies.
We're all going to have to
buy at least 1,000 each.
[LAUGHTER]
You know what I mean?
And we had this vision of,
I'm just going to the toilet.
No, don't go in
there, because that's
where the books would be.
You'd open the door,
and they'd all fall out.
So what happened was I
published the book, 10,000.
I haven't a clue.
I actually probably only should
have printed 500 or 1,000.
But I was interviewed on
Ireland AM with Ryan Turbidy.
And actually, the book came out
on Adam's first anniversary.
So to have, within that year--
and on his first anniversary,
we had a new baby as well.
And the reason why I'm saying
that was we didn't back down.
We knew we were in trouble.
And we said, we've got
to get out of this.
No one can help us out of this.
We can ring Joe Duffy
all day, and we're not
going to get anywhere with him.
Because he's going to
hear my story, and then
they'll be on to the next one.
We had a major fight on our hand
for the survival of our family
and our minds as well.
And so that's what we did.
So within the first year
and Adam's anniversary,
we had a baby girl.
So now we had an angel
in heaven, two boys,
and a little girl.
We had a book coming out.
And life was still hard,
but it was beautiful.
It was wonderful.
And it was very special.
"Before You Sleep"
went to number one.
It sold 10,000
copies in six weeks.
And I went, OK, that's easy.
Do all books do this?
And ignorance is
wonderful, because I just
thought that was it.
So I went on to my printer
and I said, another 10,000.
And she said, you're mad.
You're just mad.
Don't-- you've had run.
The way the industry
works, you have a big blip,
and then it all fizzes out.
And I went, oh, look,
I'll sell them somewhere.
I have my website, and so on.
So then another 10,000.
And they were gone
before Christmas.
So I launched them
the 13th of August,
and 20,000 copies were
gone before Christmas.
And I was on for
another reprint.
And she said, OK, I know
I told you the last time
not to go mad, but
don't go mad this time.
I went, 10,000 copies.
And then I had my 10,000
copies, and February came.
And then I went, I still
have 10,000 copies.
And then March came, I
still have 10,000 copies.
Because the Christmas
period had run.
I was still working at
Vodafone at the time.
I wrote my second book,
which was a space adventure.
And that came out
after a huge event
in my life with the
book, which was I
entered "Before You Sleep"
into the Irish Book Awards.
Now, to be a
self-published author,
I didn't have a publisher.
I don't have an agent.
I don't have any publicity
and all that sort of stuff.
That book was taken in
to a shortlist of four.
And I got as many of my family
around a 10-seater table--
I think we had 13--
and we stuffed them all in.
And it was more of a thank you
to them, not expecting to win,
but hoping.
It was a thank
you for my family,
because they helped
us through so much.
And I said, look,
this is a celebration.
So I'm got emotional because
I'm thinking of the night.
So when we won the book
award, I was sitting down,
and they were going through it.
I hear the nominations.
And the winner is, and I'm
going, oh, my god, oh, my god,
oh, my god.
And it was Benji Bennett
for "Before You Sleep."
I can't tell you the
feeling that that was--
not because I won a book award.
I didn't care about that.
But it was Adam was there.
It's his message, and
he's minding his dad.
So for me, that was more
about this message is real.
Adam is real.
He is pushing me.
He is driving me.
He is inspiring me
to do what I'm doing.
Ever since then,
I haven't stopped.
I've now written eight books.
I've been nominated for four
of the times for Irish Book
Awards, and I won it
again for my other book,
"Before You Sleep."
I launched "Before You
Sleep" over in America.
Now, again, I'm on my own, so
I don't have a big financing
backing behind me.
And I went to the
London Book Fair,
and I found a
distributor in the US.
And they said, OK,
we like this book.
We're going to take it on.
And I went, great.
And I said, look, I think I'll
be able to get some publicity.
So went off to the printer and
I said, 20,000 books for the US.
And she goes, Jesus.
[LAUGHTER]
And it is later.
And so I have my 20,000
paperbacks printed.
And then my distributor
comes along and said,
look I was in with
Barnes and Noble.
And they said if you can get
the publicity over in America,
they'll take your book in.
But they want a hard copy.
And I'm like, OK, well, I've
just printed 20,000 softbacks
with the dollar
and all the rest,
and now you want hard backs.
And I went, OK, it's just stock.
I'll eventually sell
them, and whatever.
So off we went, and I printed
15,000 hardback copies,
sent them over to
the US last August.
And I got in touch with a
PR agent over in the US.
And she said, yeah, I
think I can get you on.
This is going to be great.
It's brilliant.
And oh, my god.
And of course,
then, on to "Ellen,"
and on to "The Today Show,"
and all these kind of guys.
Oh, no, not at the moment.
And Donald Trump is
all over the news.
And I was trying to launch my
book at the worst possible time
in US political
history, because it was
Donald and Hillary everywhere.
You just couldn't get anything.
So I didn't get any
publicity whatsoever.
And then the distributor
came, and they said,
you haven't got the publicity.
Barnes and Noble are not
taking in any of your books.
And I'm going, oh, Jesus, I've
got 20,000 softbacks, 15,000
hardbacks.
Oh, my god.
And nobody is selling them.
So I got on to my beloved
Adam's Cloud Facebook page.
Adam's Army is what I call them.
It's an army of people who
are helping me and carrying me
through by spreading the message
of the love of hugs and kisses.
And I said, guys, just
launched over in America.
If we can get some
good reviews on Amazon,
that means Amazon
might present my book
to more of their customers,
and we might sell some.
Again, ignorance is bliss.
I didn't have a clue.
So 500 five-star reviews
later within three days,
I'm going, oh, my god.
This is unbelievable.
And it wasn't just that
they were five-star reviews.
It's what people said about
the "Before You Sleep" book.
It's touched people
on such a level.
The stories I can
tell you how it's
helped people who have
lost their children,
and how it's helped people
with sick children--
grandparents,
parents, everybody--
they were fanatical in
what they were writing.
It was like, buy this book.
Buy this book.
Just don't even think about it.
And then there was a case
of, OK, that's great.
I have these reviews up,
but nobody is seeing it.
So I started
advertising on Facebook.
And all of a sudden, the
sales started coming in.
And I went, oh, that's--
I'm looking at my
chart position.
120,000.
that's not bad.
That's out of all
of books on Amazon.
OK.
100,000, great.
That's brilliant.
90,000, 50,000, oh, my god,
10,000, oh, my god, in the top
selling 10,000 books.
I don't have a publisher.
Nobody knows about
me over in America.
It's on Amazon.com.
This is amazing.
5,000, brilliant.
On Black Friday,
we got to number 3
in the children's charts and
number 600 over all books.
So I'm competing with the
Harper-Collins, the Worldwide,
everybody, and there is my
little "Before You Sleep"
book--
again, Adam doing his
work and doing his job.
And so thankfully, in
the run-up between Amazon
and a few others, we
sold 10,000 copies
of the hardbacks in the
US without anybody knowing
who I am and no publicity.
So that, for me, is
not anything about--
my dad says, oh,
you make your luck
and all that sort of stuff.
But what it is-- and it's one of
the things I always like to get
across any time
I'm doing a talk--
is that we all need
goals in our lives.
We all need to have--
whether it's in work,
whether it's our family.
And my number one
goal when I started--
if I can try and
contain myself--
my number one goal and priority
when all of this started,
I wanted desperately for
Adam's picture to be on TV.
That was my biggest
driver behind this.
It wasn't about selling 1,000
or 100,000 or 200,000 books.
It wasn't about winning
the book awards.
I have a job.
I was just doing it.
But my one thing was I wanted
him to be on the television.
And the other thing
was I wanted to spread
this message of love, hugs, and
kisses, and help families not--
as I said, what you eat,
or what they should wear,
where you should go, and so on.
Just spend time with them.
Talk to them, engage them.
They're cleverer than we think.
And with just those two
things, this journey
has been absolutely
spectacularly amazing.
So to go from where we were,
which was deeply in love,
happily married,
this magical bubble
that I'm in-- life was
great, wasn't any [INAUDIBLE]
the average person.
We were right at the top of
the bubble, the last bubble
that we had.
And literally, the
day we lost Adam
was the day that the bubble
burst, both in Ireland
and for my own family as well.
And to be able to
go through that--
and how we made it was the
love in a family, spending time
with our children,
and just focusing
on those important
things in life.
And the important things are
providing for your family.
We've all got to work.
Some people say, oh,
the work-life balance.
We are all struggling.
But we've got to
just make that time.
And for me, if we can
inspire our children
and make that
difference-- because they
are the new legislators.
They are the new politicians.
They are the new government.
They're the new Googlers.
They are the new doctors.
They are everybody.
And if they have
compassion and love
and affection in their life,
that's the multiplier effect.
And I think we can
make a big change.
And that's probably
a half an hour or so.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: Thank you,
Benji, for sharing
your story and Adam's story.
It's special.
It's obviously very emotional.
So we'll start with
a lighter question.
BENJI BENNETT: Good.
SPEAKER: You worked in
business originally,
and then you took a
very big leap of faith.
When did you know that-- other
than the bathroom door that
couldn't be opened because
it was full of books, what
[INAUDIBLE] that?
BENJI BENNETT: It was
almost immediately.
Because again, what
happened to us--
and as I said at
the start, everybody
has something that
they're struggling with.
Everybody does.
And you see them on the street,
and they may have a bad day.
I knew straight
away I did not want
to be the guy in the office.
Leave him.
He's a bit mad.
His son died a few
years ago, and he's--
we just leave him in here
and hide in this kind
of corporate environment.
I would have lost, and I would
have died myself in there.
Because selling
minutes on a network,
what did that mean
to me anymore?
It didn't mean anything to me.
Doing this analysis and
being passionate about-- you
know what we should do?
Because I was always
very passionate in work.
So I almost knew, straight
away, that I needed
to do something different.
So when I started writing the
book, it was like when I'm--
there was no plan.
I just started doing it, because
I had this goal of change
the world on my own and spread
this message of love, hugs,
and kisses.
So that's really
where it happened.
I knew I needed a change,
both in work, what I did,
and the life that I led.
SPEAKER: So you have three
surviving children, Harry,
Robbie, and Molly.
How old are they now?
BENJI BENNETT: So
Harry is now 16.
He is on transition year.
He is building a
community center in Brazil
as part of that.
So yes.
And so they have to raise
their funds, and he's gone off.
And 17 in the class.
120 were picked.
And it's an amazing experience,
and he's so excited.
He's been on the phone,
and it's brilliant.
Then we have Robbie, who he is
10, and Molly, who is eight.
There's two years between them.
They are best friends.
They are like that.
And a lot of my
social media content--
because Harry is off doing
his thing, pretty much--
a lot of my social media
is just what they're doing,
and the fun, where
I'm bringing them,
what I'm doing with
them, the conversations
that they have together.
It's just brilliant, and I
love to observe them as well.
SPEAKER: Harry features
in some of your books,
in the "Space Adventure."
And the others, do they
have a feature as well?
BENJI BENNETT: "Before We
Sleep" was my first one,
and that was Adam the
character with a parent.
Now, as you can see
from the photographs
with the ripped muscles,
it's 100% shaped
on my physique and good looks.
So that's a joke, of course.
And then the "Space" book,
because Harry was 6 and 1/2
when I lost Adam, I wanted
to have something for him.
So it was Harry and Adam,
just the two of them,
went off on this big adventure.
The next one was
a Christmas one,
because I'm a nutter
for Christmas,
and I love Christmas.
And there's a lovely message
in the Christmas book.
And that's when I
introduced Fluff.
Because as my kids
were small, they
weren't getting up to mischief
or going on adventures.
So it was just Adam and Fluff.
And then on my fourth book,
"Adam's Pirate Treasure,"
that's when I introduced
all of the kids into it.
And Molly is in that, and so on.
So they've grown,
and my books have
grown as I've grown as a dad,
as my children have grown.
And yeah, all my
kids are in them.
Fluff flies them
wherever they need.
And now this year, I have a new
book coming out in September,
and Bailey, our dog, is now
part of the action as well.
So we got close to the
"Famous Five" going on there.
SPEAKER: And has the
age range changed, then,
for the focus of the books?
BENJI BENNETT: No.
Some of my books would be a
little bit more educational.
My invention is one, it's
time travel and inventions.
We don't have Google as
the invention in there.
So we have Apple, all right.
SPEAKER: Not yet.
BENJI BENNETT: So they will
deal with certain themes.
So the inventions, or
even the world of wonders,
what's the most wonderful
thing in the world.
And they go off looking
for it, like we all do.
We're trying to find out
what's the most wonderful thing
in the world.
And it's represented by the
Colosseum, the Pyramids,
and the Taj Mahal.
And Adam comes
back, and he goes,
I don't think I've
quite found it.
I just don't feel I've got it.
And then it's a kiss
and a hug at bedtime,
and a big hug and a squeeze.
And he goes, ah, that's--
I didn't have to leave my home,
because that's what it is.
So the illustrations
are very broad.
Some of the themes will
be a little bit older.
But the age range is from babies
to about nine years of age.
So I'm very lucky with that.
SPEAKER: So slightly
more personal question.
And after this one, then we'll
open up to audience questions.
I'm not a mother yet--
I'll had to qualify.
But I have two
beautiful nephews.
And I don't struggle in any way
telling them that I love them.
I probably don't say it
enough, but I'll improve
after hearing your talk.
But saying I love you is
difficult to another adult--
maybe not to a
husband or a wife,
but to your friend or your
brother or your sister.
That's more difficult. Have you
been asked for advice on that
before, or have any impressions?
BENJI BENNETT: It's funny.
I've never been asked
that question before.
And yes, it is a
kind of a funny one.
Now, my kids will tell
each other they love them,
and they tell me I
love them, and so on.
And that that's a
normal family thing.
But as you get older, it
does seem to be friends
and so on are--
when you're in
school or whatever,
if you told your best friend
you loved him, oh, god I
think he's gay, or whatever.
You'd have that type of thing.
So to say those words--
it's not just about saying them.
And that's why I was
talking about time,
spending time with them
and inspiring them.
For example, when I was younger,
my dad [INAUDIBLE] myself--
we have six kids, and
two of them were younger,
and two of my
brothers were older.
And myself and my sister
were kind of in the middle.
And there was a stage where my
dad would bring the two of us
up to the mountains, and
we'd go with the dog.
And I loved it.
And to this day, I still
absolutely love it.
And I remember the chats
that we would have up there.
Do you know what I mean?
And even at the time
of the Stardust fire,
we were actually up
at the top of that.
And I remember that.
And he just gave me a hug.
And sorry.
I'm thinking of the
people in that tragedy.
But he gave me a hug.
And he didn't say I love you.
But we were up on the
top of a mountain.
I was, whatever, nine
years or 10 years of age,
or whatever it was.
And it was a
wonderful experience.
And all of those walks I loved.
Now, he has inspired me.
This is why I'm talking about
the inspiration for children.
He has inspired me to do
that with my children.
And my children love going out.
They're outdoorsy.
They climb trees, they do that.
And they are healthy
and they're happy.
And so that expression of
love doesn't necessarily
have to be verbal.
You can tell somebody
you love them.
But if I don't put the bins out
for my wife, she's kind of--
I'd have to do that, because--
not to show her that I love her,
but it's because I love her.
That's why I'm going to do it.
So it doesn't have
to be the words.
I think the actions are
very important to do that.
So saying the words
can be uncomfortable.
Don't worry.
Just do the nice
things, I think.
But always tell the
kids you love them,
because they're smaller, and
they need to be told as well.
But I think we all need
to be told we're loved.
Am I right?
I think we are.
So tell your neighbors now.
You can tell each other
you love each other.
Hi, guy.
I love you.
Hugs for everybody at lunchtime.
I'm serious.
SPEAKER: Would anyone
like to ask a question?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So the
question is, why
you chose writing [INAUDIBLE]
BENJI BENNETT: Well, the
big goal, eventually,
is puppets and TV
screens and movies
and all that sort of stuff.
But no, I had never
written before.
But in Vodafone, I
had to communicate.
I used to kind of joke,
it's like, right, I've
got to catch all these people
who know nothing about pricing,
what's going on and so on.
So my communication
skills were developed
in a business environment.
Why the writing?
Again, there was no
thought process here.
So we lost Adam.
We were absolutely devastated.
We had a young one-year-old.
And I just sat down, and
I just started writing.
And I just wanted to remember
the fun that I had with Adam,
because I had very late video.
And we didn't have a huge
amount of photographs of him,
because there was no
camera phones back then,
unfortunately.
So I went, I have certain
things I have to remember.
I have to remember his
spirit and his smile.
That's why I wrote--
it was for myself.
And a lot of people who
have gone through trauma
like that will write, because it
gives them something out of it.
And so that was it.
And then to be able
to put something
in the hand of parents where
the words are from the parent
into the child's ear are
the words, "I love you,"
there can't be a more
powerful, stronger
way of delivering
Adam's message there.
And that's really what it was.
So I never wanted
to be a writer.
Who knows?
AUDIENCE: What was
the editing process
that you followed
to get [INAUDIBLE]
and given for
children's storybooks
that the illustrations are
such a big component of it?
BENJI BENNETT: Thanks for that.
So I'll come on to the
editing bit in a minute.
Any time I'm writing a
book, I have a full vision
of exactly what my crazy
kids are doing in the scene.
And I know where
Fluff is going to be,
and I know the environment
they're going to be in.
So for the first one,
it's I love you much more
than the deepest blue sea.
And I said, OK, we've got to
have the parent and the child
going on an
adventure underwater.
And crazy stuff-- well,
fishes go to school.
You'd be inspired
by certain Disney.
I love the Disney
stuff, Nemos and stuff.
And I went, OK, so we need
all the fishes going to school
and the submarine bosses.
You know what I mean?
Oh, there's a line.
So as I'm doing my writing,
those images are in my head.
Now, I can never imagine how
they're going to turn out.
So when I'd finished the
book-- and it's funny.
That was in crumples of paper.
And I'd go out to any
stranger who would listen.
I had a beard, long hair.
My jumper was on inside
out and back to front.
I was like a crazy man.
Have a look at that, and they
go, that's really lovely.
And of course they're
going to say that,
because it's a crumpled
piece of paper, and so on.
But a lot of the feedback that
I did get was very powerful.
They just said,
it's very simple.
So on my first book, I
wrote a 30-page brief
on the illustrations.
So I sent pictures
of Adam, any videos
that we had with the team.
I wanted everything to be happy.
I wanted a tree to be smiling.
I wanted the submarine
to have a smile.
Everything was
personalized in the book.
It's this wonderful
world of happiness.
It's my bubble.
And then I got into some
detail on the specific images.
So I gave an overall theme
and then the specific ones.
And luckily, I found
a great illustrator
through Cartoon Saloon.
Spent a fortune on it.
I went to the bank.
And again, didn't-- no plan.
I went to the bank
and I said, I need
12 grand for illustrations.
And they're going, oh,
jeez, it's 10,000 books.
And no thought
process whatsoever.
It was just that inspiration
of get Adam on the TV
and spread the message.
And then the editing was--
I got a--
I think it was a D in
passing, [INAUDIBLE]
probably because they couldn't
understand my writing.
But punctuation is probably
my biggest, and grammar.
So I just got
somebody I knew who
was able to straighten it out.
They didn't change, necessarily,
anything that I wrote.
They just fixed it up
for glaring mistakes.
And there is one or two
that I go, oh, sugar,
we missed that one.
So that's the process
that I went through.
And again, just kept it simple.
AUDIENCE: I lost my nephew
just over Christmas,
and my brother and
his girlfriend,
they're still going
to work everyday.
They're trying to cope with it.
I was wondering, what
advice do you have,
what kept you going
in your darkest hours?
BENJI BENNETT: First of all,
my condolences to both you
and your family, because it
does extend to the whole family.
And everybody here has got
either a parent, a cousin,
a brother, a sister,
somebody, or your aunt.
And grief is so different
for so many different people.
Very close friends of ours had
a particularly tragic situation,
and he's barely operating.
And you don't operate properly
for the first year, as I said.
I would just sit
in a chair, and I'd
be talking, thinking I was OK.
But people looking inward
are going, oh, my god,
they're a mess.
And for you looking in
at them, it's like that--
I always use the
backseat driver analogy.
If you're ever driving
a car, you're fine.
You're in control.
But if my wife is driving the
car, it's like, oh, my god,
she's driving too close,
or she's not looking,
or does she see that bike.
And you're worrying about them.
It's the same with grief.
When you're looking
in on it, you're
just looking at their raw pain.
Now, they have it, and it's
horrific, and it is survivable.
For me-- and what I've learned
with the work I've done with
Barretstown--Barretstown--[MUSIC PLAYING]
I've raised 50,000 euros from
donations through the
books to charities--
what I've learned is it's
a celebration for me.
Adam was always a celebration.
As I said, when we
lost him, it was
quite a beautiful experience.
His funeral was so magical.
And then you have your
meltdown and your breakdown,
and you'll have that.
Keeping busy is
always important.
But to always celebrate them.
Their child will always
be on their mind.
So never be afraid to--
people say to me, oh, gosh,
I don't know him from Adam.
You know that expression?
It's an Irish expression.
And they go, oh, god, I'm sorry.
I say, it's fine.
I was thinking about Adam
before you even said that.
So they would always
be thinking of them.
All you can do is just keep
ringing, just meeting, just
listen from your perspective.
For them, they just have to
find their way, and celebration.
And usually doing something,
whether it's planting a tree,
or putting up a
bench, or whatever.
Just to do something for
them is always a nice thing.
But it's impossible to
imagine what you go through.
I can't even imagine it now,
because we're 10 years on,
and we are blissfully
happy, and Adam is amazing,
and our life is so spiritual,
and everything around us
is wonderful.
But when you're starting
off, it's just no hope.
And to talk to other people
who have lost their children as
well-- because for me, I didn't
want to hear anybody's story.
I just wanted to hear
how long have you gone
and how was your life.
Because I was so fearful that
I was going to be finished.
AUDIENCE: Last question,
I saw in one of your books
that you collaborate
with LauraLynn,
so could you tell us
something about that?
BENJI BENNETT: So when
I wrote my first book,
as I was writing it, we
went on a bereavement camp
with Barretstown.
And again, no plan.
So when we lost Adam,
there was a golf thing on,
and it was cancer.
So all of the money for it
was just given to a charity.
And somebody suggested
to me Barretstown.
I didn't know.
I heard of them, but I
didn't know much about them.
And I said, whatever.
And then when we went down,
we went on a bereavement camp.
And I said, Joan, it
would be nice to be
able to do something extra.
Now, in my commercial
mind, I knew
that I wouldn't be able
to do the whole thing just
for a charity.
I was hoping that maybe it
would be something that I
could make a career out of.
I wasn't too sure.
So I said, look, I just want
to make a small donation
from the sale of each book.
The idea is that as long
as I'm alive and as long
as that book is
selling, you're going
to get the percentage
straight off the top.
And they went, oh, god.
We'd love that.
Thanks a million.
So that's how that started.
Then when I was doing
the "Space" book,
Make A Wish contacted me.
They said, we heard
about your book.
Would you be interested in
helping us grant wishes?
And I went, Adam granting
wishes, oh, my god.
That's the best thing ever.
So they got the next two books.
Then LauraLynn is a
charity I know well enough
through person, but
I just know of them,
and I love the work
that they're doing.
So I rang them.
I said, look, I'm
doing my books.
You don't have to do anything.
I'm not asking for anything.
Do you want this presented?
And they went, great.
So that's really what it is.
And then Anamara as well is a
parent's bereavement support
group.
So that's really--
it's all charity,
children-related charities
that I'm helping.
So I love it, and it's amazing.
And for Adam to grant wishes
and help families is incredible.
SPEAKER: It's amazing, Benji.
You've done wonders
for his memory.
BENJI BENNETT: Thank you.
SPEAKER: It's beautiful.
Can you tell us--
you have eight books?
BENJI BENNETT: Eight books.
SPEAKER: One jigsaw?
BENJI BENNETT: One jigsaw.
SPEAKER: And you're in
the US, so what's next?
BENJI BENNETT: Oh, god.
Well, in the US,
it's just trying
to get the US going
a little bit better.
I have a new book
coming out in September.
A lot of where I'm
selling them now
is through the bookshops
online, but a lot of events.
I was in the [INAUDIBLE] at
the Pregnancy and Baby Fair.
So a lot of promoting
all the time,
because at the end of the
day, it's what pays the bills.
And so I am out a
lot of the time.
I'd like to be doing a
little bit more blogging.
But the last year has
been very successful.
And if we have a good year--
so hopefully, all you Googlers
can tell all those Googlers
in America about my books.
And when I'm doing
my book tour, I'll
go and do a talk
over there as well.
SPEAKER: Yeah, absolutely.
We'll have to look in to it.
Thank you very much
for sharing your story.
BENJI BENNETT:
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]